[Music]
i have a phrase my phrase is technology
fails until it succeeds
the point is
what will you
as an individual
choose to use as your technology to
avoid
starving to death or freezing to death
economically that's the question so the
mobile way was
software leaping off of the desktop and
out of the office and into the world of
the teenager
and on a saturday afternoon and that's
what made for a facebook
or an amazon uh mobile
you know or google or youtube you know
and laid the laid the framework for
entertainment and communications now
we're moving on the virtual wave you're
seeing the virtualization of a whole
class of products and services that
previously were delivered
uh by human beings
you can zoom anywhere at the speed of
light and bend time and space if i'm a
salesperson i can take 40 sales calls a
week if i want in 40 different cities
but the other profound part of it is
what you just did when we started our
call which is you punch the record
button
and
you and i are having a meeting
cross country
and that's about to be shared with
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
people
anywhere
anytime
three years from now
someone will be able to go back in time
three years and be in the room with us
now
for the cost of electricity we're
watching the virtualization of money so
i can tell you that
gold that i have and if this were a real
nobel prize it would be worth about
twenty four thousand dollars and uh and
that gold came from the collision of two
enormous neutron stars and that happened
perhaps five billion years ago in our
region of the galaxy and the neutron
enrichment basically a giant atom not a
56 neutron but 10 to the 56 neutrons or
something like that coming together the
shrapnel of which produced the gold uh
and that we find now you're saying we're
only going to have you know 21 million
coins that are subdivided into so many
satoshi's or what bitcoin but i don't
think there's going to be another
neutron star that put it this way if
another neutron star collides near the
earth we've got much bigger problems in
our monetary situation but you know the
fact is that's much more scarce than
my friend down the street minds bitcoin
uh in other words how can we be so
certain that it is it has this
permanence and it has this durability
and resilience that it makes it a true
store of money the way that these
neutron stars did for us many billions
of years ago
um
the history of money is
is human beings looking for some
for some system that they can use to
store and trade value both with each
other and with themselves over time with
some commodities they're really easy to
produce the hardest commodity
to produce that also had the
characteristics that we wanted for money
was gold i mean because we needed it to
be durable and stable like it needs to
it needs to last a thousand years we
mine gold gold miners produce about two
percent more gold every year that means
that if i took all of all of the money
in the world and i bought gold with it
and i had 100 of the gold in the world
100 years from now i would have 12 and a
half percent of the gold in the world
gold is centralized which means uh you
can hypothecate it and you can sell it
short
there's no way for you to be sure that
the bank that holds all your gold didn't
actually sell the gold twice without
telling you
uh because you can't reasonably withdraw
100 million dollars of gold and stored
underneath your mattress
but
and so that means that uh gold has
always been plagued uh by people issuing
notes against the gold without enough
gold to cover it if you look at
something like bitcoin bitcoin is
audited every 10 minutes by 10 000 nodes
so it's very it's very challenging and
not impossible to lie about it
those 100 million people can take
personal custody if they want
because it has no mass
what's the prevent you know a really
black swan event as tele would say
from you know government just saying
you're this is now illegal and any
proceeds we want to know the history of
every single coin
a lot of people
are working very hard to come up with
some reason why
they shouldn't trust a new thing
meanwhile
it's quite clear that 7.8 billion people
on the planet have a problem
everybody with money on earth is going
to lose half their wealth in the next 48
months if they do nothing if you live if
you're one of the billion people in a
collapsing developed economy you're
going to lose everything if you do
nothing the solution
is a digital monetary network that
doesn't dissipate energy that you can
access
where no one can corrupt it and you can
take personal custody of your money of
your monetary energy the laws of
thermodynamics and the conservation of
energy
right what's at the core of bitcoin
is the laws of thermodynamics and the
conservation of energy if i put
a million dollars of monetary energy
into the network in the year 2020
i can go forward 250 years or 50 years
or 10 years or whatever amount of time
frame you want and i will have the same
amount of monetary energy scaled up
perfectly linearly
you know for the economic growth
without
any individual stealing at all
if you take the same amount of monetary
energy and you put it into the dollar
you will lose 99
of that energy it will be stolen from
you
by the central bank and the fractional
reserve bankers over the course of 100
years maybe over the course of 10 to 15
years
when you live in the universe
you have to subject yourself to the laws
of thermodynamics you don't get to
create energy or destroy energy or
create mass or destroy
there's a conservation of this stuff you
can't leap a million gazillion miles we
don't have a world where you get to leap
a million miles an hour and murder
everybody and the guy next to you
doesn't
right you're both subject to the same
laws of thermodynamics
in that world but in the world of fiat
there's one dude
that can steal the life work of a
billion people
in a minute
on a whim
and there's another person
that can't
so the significance of bitcoin is you
can take
a portion of monetary energy you can
store it on a network
that no politician
no bank no counterparty
can seize from you against your will and
nobody can debase or inflate away
via some uh some political edict
which is not the case with any other
monetary system on earth what is the
purpose of wealth to you
money
is monetary energy
monetary energy is the apex of all
energies wealth is just uh energy and
you can channel it however you want
and it ultimately gets channeled based
upon the values
of the people with the energy right or
listeners that ask me you know how can i
talk to people that have so much power
the ability to convert energy
and do work in a very brief amount of
time those obviously you're not going to
construct a mercenary army i hope you
know with with some of your money but
not on my agenda it would be a bad
investment anyway and have more energy
you can have more money but we're also
living in the most polarized you know
discrepancy between those that can apply
energy for in the shortest amount of
time and those that cannot um how do you
does that affect you do you think about
that if i have 25 trillion dollars of
currency floating around and i just
print another trillion
i just seized four percent of all the
power in the civilization
and i just did it by fiat right by edict
without even a law being passed
right so so the biggest power
discrepancy is is the current
uh power to print money currency
and that leads to all the other power
discrepancies and if you want to reverse
that
then you need you need to educate the
world so that people understand that
they should switch
from the fiat standard to the bitcoin
standard because if you're on the
bitcoin standard nobody could print more
bitcoin and deprive you
of your monetary energy
the swimming pool won't work the
airplane won't fly the ship won't
sail
the electrical system won't work with
the short circuit the pneumatic system
won't work with a leak in it you know
nothing works in the engineering world
if you don't have you know integrity and
a closed system
and nothing works in math
if you just change the number right i
mean the point is math is math so if you
want to reject all of math all of
thermodynamics all of science the
conservation of energy and the universe
then yeah
you can run your society based upon fiat
currency with one individual that makes
up however much money they want to make
up at any given time
but it seems pretty clear that
the rest of the universe doesn't work
that way
what does it mean to talk about the
thermodynamics of bitcoin
or anything in particular
when it comes to computation or storage
of information i'm going to give a quick
overview of a physicist view of such a
process and take you through an exercise
in the calculation of what
thermodynamics really is all about which
is entropy
entropy is a measure of disorder of
chaos of ignorance of lack of
information or clutter in a system
and it's often talked about in computer
context
and especially in the application of
computers by michael saylor in the video
you just saw
in the context of how easy how simple
how thermodynamically sound
such
currency is and we're going to consider
the most basic process in computing
which is the act of forgetting which is
the act of erasing and the question is
when you erase information how much
energy is required to conduct that
process in a computer how would you
actually do it
well you can bound how much uh would
need to be done by considering the
changing of every single bit of
information stored in a computer
uh in a byte of information in a
gigabyte of information uh computers use
uh in the context of bitcoin they use
256 bits for encrypting uh certain
aspects of the ledger of the blockchain
so i'm going to use the example of
looking at the erasing
of a
of an amount of memory known as a
gigabyte so a gigabyte is
1024 megabytes
a megabyte is 1024 kilobytes
and a kilobyte is 1024 bytes now what is
a byte a byte is eight bits so that
could be represented by eight light
bulbs uh where the light bulbs could
either be on or off it could be
represented in computer memory by zeros
and ones zero volts five volts etc and
so that's how we represent computers
represent memory first question is if
your computer rates and overwrites over
all that
one gigabyte worth of memory and keeps
no record of the information that was
stored i want to ask the question of how
much process what what how much in that
process how much entropy
is created second law of thermodynamics
that michael saylor refers to is always
about this law that entropy can never
decrease so entropy will be representing
it mathematically in this short little
conversation and the question is once
you have that much entropy
and you've now dumped it into the larger
system of the room in which the computer
is sitting how much heat
how much thermal energy is associated
with that is it a large amount of heat
is it a small amount of heat and then
you imagine how much uh memory how many
times is done every second on the
blockchain the question is how much
energy does this actually take so
entropy if we regard
the calculation of entropy we note that
there are if there are n bits
uh which is a slot you can think of as a
slot or a placeholder and a transistor
and each one can take on a value high or
low uh zero or one then you actually
have two states for each for each bit so
you have two to the n possible different
states so we can convert a gigabyte
into
a megabyte and then a megabyte into a
kilobyte
etc and then eventually we convert the
number of bytes into bits and then we've
got 2 to the 10th times 2 to the 10th
times 2 to the 10th times 2 to the third
and if you calculate that at home you
get 2 to the 33rd power
bits of information so that is the total
amount of bits represented in one
gigabyte now it could either be in one
of two states a zero or one so that
means if you have n bits that's two to
the n different states that are possible
in calculating the total available
amount of of of entropy that means that
the number of states there are is 2 to
the 2 to the 33rd power it turns out
that entropy
usually involves a calculation of very
large numbers and so to simplify the
large numbers we realized since the time
of boltzmann that the entropy is most
conveniently expressed in terms of a
logarithm of the number of states so the
exact expression that boltzmann has on
his tombstone is that
it relates the amount of entropy
times his famous constant k and we get
an entropy of 8.2 times 10 to the minus
14 joules per kelvin a joule is a
relatively small number too
but we said we're doing this this
calculation all the computers that do
operate on bitcoin they do it at room
temperature and so the room temperature
we'd multiply by 300 and we still don't
get a very large number we're getting
something that is going to be
a very very tiny amount in temperature
uh of additional temperature that's
added to the to the world or additional
heat rather that's added to the world in
terms of joules we get
uh by multiplying this increase in
entropy this 8 times 10 to the minus 14
joules per kelvin times room temperature
is about 300 kelvin we get an
almost infinitesimal or microscopic
amount of energy which is equal to the
amount of of heat that will be dumped
into the environment and we get an
answer that's about 2.4 times
10 to the minus 11 joules now is that a
big number or is that a small number
turns out it's a small number but again
we only considered the multiplication of
these bits or changing of these bits
from zeros to ones for one gigabyte
worth of memory in a computer at room
temperature
so that's a small amount of energy
required for a gigabyte but if you
imagine terabytes which are thousands of
gigabytes or 10 or thousands of
thousands of terabytes uh that could be
conceivable for a supercomputer farm
that's operating perhaps at a bitcoin
farm you could get many many joules per
second or
however often the bitcoin the blockchain
is up updated so it's it could be that
it is not insignificant but i did want
to only illuminate from a physics point
of view where
are these operations coming into play
what is actually causing the increase in
energy or requiring energy it's actually
a process related in thermodynamics to
the entropy
of both creation or storage of
information and not destruction of
information we physicists don't believe
that's possible there is some trace of
the of the process that was used to
erase that could in principle
be used in a reversible process to
recover the information but you could
never recover that heat that heat is
lost forever to the universe and can no
longer be recovered to do anything
useful such as
writing new information or producing
matter and anti-matter in pairs for
example
so it is a process and under which is
governed by the laws of thermodynamics